[موسيقى]
الكريم لن يرد على الحرب قد تنتهي غدا اذا
اردت صوره لبنانيه
واسعه اول تعليق الرسمي حول تهديد رونالدو
الرحيل عن المنتخب هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقولها لكم من قناه العربيه
الروسيه
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه على الاقل حتى
نهايه 2015
اثارت صوره لابي اللبناني غضبا واسعا في
مواقع التواصل بعدما ظهر وهو يحمل جثه طفل
رضيع ملفوفا بقطعه قماش ويسير بها في
الشارع بعد ما اجبر على رهن سيارته
للمستشفى
الاب الذي يدعى حسين قرر العربيه ان
المستشفى ابلغ هو بوفاه ابنه وطلب منه
2000 و 2400 دولار بدل علاج مشيرا الى انه
ابلغ المعنيين بانه لا يملك المال وسيقوم
بتامين لاحقا ليطلب منه قسم المحاسبه رحنا
سيارته ريتما ياتي المال فيما طالب حسين
المعنيين بفتح تحقيق شفاف للمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن الحادثات
وفي اخي المستجدات قضيه الفنان المصري
محمد رمضان ضد مواطن الاعلاميه عمرو اديب
اثرت محكمه وجون حسين
تقارير افادت بين الحكم اتى بعد دعوه
قضائيه اقامها رمضان ضد اديب الذي حمل
الممثله الشهير في برنامجه المسؤوليه
المباشره عن وفاه الطيار اشرف ابو اليسر
بعدما تسبب في وقفه عن العمل
موعدا للنطق بالحكمه
وهيلا اخبار المونديال هذه المره راح يكون
فريق اتحاد البرتغالي لكره القدم التقارير
التي اشارت الى تهديد النجم كريستيانو
رونالدو بمغادره معسكر المنتخب في قطر
الاتحاد البرتغالي اوضح في بيانيا ان قائد
المنتخب لم يحدث في اي لحظه بمغادره
الفريق خلال بطوله كاس العالم في قطر في
مكانات
سويسرا به دور ال16 قبل ان يدفع به في
الدقيقه الثالثه والسبعين من عمر اللقاء
وفي خبرنا الاخير وبعد الهجوم الذي تعرض
له منتخب البرازيل بسبب رقص لاعبيه بعد كل
هدف قال نجم البرازيلي واللاعب السابق ليو
جونيور ان الرقص هو جزء متاثر في الثقافه
البرازيليه اللاعب المعروف بانه اول من
بدا هذا التقليد اثناء مباراه البرازيل
بمونديال 82 قال لي الصحفيين اننا لا نرقص
لاننا نرقص على حد تعبير
عن الرقص او رقصه اللاعب المنتخب
الاحتفاليه بعد فوزهم على كوريا الجنوبيه
بالقول ان الرقص يعبر عن السعاده ويساعد
بالتقرب اكثر من اللاعبين
[موسيقى]